what's going on guys this is Rob and I
have so many updates somebody updates
for you guys I know a lot of you guys
been asking where I've been like why I
haven't uploaded parts 3 & 4
of Avengers disassembled and the death
of Wolverine and there's a basically one
big reason because I was assembling my
new computer then I blew it up and by
that point my old computer was gone so I
had to buy a new one so that'll be here
on Monday but for right now I'm using my
my macbook pro I'm gonna use my macbook
like i'm gonna transition like all my
software over like i'm gonna you know
install like after effects and and adobe
audition and photoshop and Premiere Pro
and all that kind of stuff so that I can
have this as like a backup system won't
be nearly as powerful as my Intel but
it'll still be it also be pretty awesome
so be pretty good as far as my main PC
goes and the ability to like render
stuff but any red that's that's neither
here nor there you guys don't care about
that kind of stuff so that's basically
it like my computer just blew up so so
yeah I'm waiting on a new one to get
here I've also ordered a ps4 so you know
hopefully we'll be able to play some
games together I know Vinny and I we're
trying to have been trying to get
together and play games for a while
which which leads me into the the first
the first major update as you guys know
we're moving towards the beginning of
the year when this is going to be a
full-time job and with that it comes the
I guess the notion that before when we
had like 50,000 subscribers when we had
30 or we had you know 60 or 70 or
something like that it was endearing
that they were like flubs in my audio
where I was like uh and making mistakes
and people were like oh that's so cute
you know he's starting out and stuff but
we've crushed that hundred thousand
subscriber threshold all that's got to
change all that's got to go away like we
have to make these videos more
professional and so in order to do that
there's a few things that I'm
implementing I'm changing my intro and I
know a lot of you guys are really like
no why would you change your intro Rob
honestly because thirty seconds is just
too long I mean I love that intro I
think it's a fantastic intro and I hate
to see it go but in the direction that
we're going in we've got to be able to
get videos out pretty quick and we've
got to be able to do them consistently
and so I think having something that's
like a 5 to 10 second intro is it's
perfect I mean it's right there and it's
too
point people know what they're watching
and we can just begin jump right into
the video which brings me to the next
thing the next thing is the length of
videos because I'm gonna be doing this
full-time because we're gonna be like
moving forward and catching up with
current events because we're gonna be
launching DC explained I'm not gonna
have time to do like 20 minute videos
that's just not really practical in
addition to that like I've been going
through and I was looking at the average
duration of people who watch my videos
the average amount of time that you guys
watch my videos and it's usually about
nine and a half minutes meaning that on
average you guys stop watching at nine
and a half minutes and if that's the
case it doesn't make any sense to do
videos that are 20 minutes long
when most people are not watching the
whole video some videos they are like
with the all-out war video from Infinity
Gauntlet you guys were watching the heck
out of that because everybody was
fighting I mean it was really cool you
know but nonetheless we're in a
situation now where we basically have to
like move this and make it more
streamlined I know for some of you guys
that's not gonna be a very popular thing
a lot of you guys are gonna be really
angry about that a lot of you guys are
gonna post angry comments you know and
and that's fun you know I understand I
understand that but the thing you guys
have to consider now is that we're in a
position to where we're we're moving
everything in a streamline direction and
you know instead of doing like these
great big huge 20 video long series that
are 20 minutes apiece we're gonna be
breaking it down and we're gonna be
doing it at a much faster rate and we're
gonna be doing it in a much cleaner way
to where they're gonna be four videos
and it's gonna have all the information
that you need but it's also going to
give you a reason to go look at Marvel
unlimited which is the next thing I
wanted to talk about if you guys don't
have Marvel unlimited I guess my
question is why Marvel unlimited is 10
bucks a month and you get the entire
Marvel catalog the only downside to it
is you have to wait six months for the
current events for the stuff that just
came out so like all new Captain America
were on issue number two right now with
Captain Falcon and you guys would have
to wait six months before you get
actually read those on Marvel unlimited
um the hähnel of that really matters to
you guys that much you know but of
course if you guys wanted me to now you
could always just go to your local comic
book store I always advocate supporting
your local comic book stores but um you
know that's that's something you guys
should really be looking at that way you
guys can even literally like follow me
in real time as we're going through
these stories you know if you guys are
curious what happens later on we could
talk about that yeah we can jump into
that and and you guys can read the
comics you know before I even get to it
so you guys can do what you do best
where you say rob you missed this Rob
you didn't you didn't say this right
this is it's different you know or
something like that which is fun you
know I love it when you guys do that
because I you know regardless of what
you guys make I may not think I don't
know everything about everything like
I'll make mistakes when it comes to
comics I love comics I've been reading
comics forever but you know I've only
got so much space up here the next thing
is is the whole like incursions thing so
if what you guys want to do if you guys
want to get like caught up basically
with what's going on with incursions if
you guys just want like a reading
explanation as opposed to a video
explanation I guess in the interim
between now and the time that we
actually get it uploaded you guys can go
to reddit.com to the Marvel summer and
I'll have a link down down in the
description and I wrote this great big
huge article that really addressed the
Illuminati and the discussion on the
Illuminati led into the incursions and
so that'll give you guys pretty much a
good explanation of what's going on up
until the point that I'm most familiar
with now there may have been a few
things that's happened since then and I
didn't really address the Galactus seed
or anything like that but nonetheless
you know those are those are things that
you guys can check in on their own and
and that explanation will pretty much
give you everything you need you know as
far as just reading and seeing what's
there what I try to do there was
basically provide information that
wasn't available on the Wikipedia
articles because they left a lot of
stuff out and so I want to make sure
like things like the mapmakers you know
I want to make sure that makes sense you
know the bridge builders the whole
purpose for those those groups and
things like that but um but yeah you
know that's that's basically the gist of
it you know we're moving this channel in
a more streamlined direction you know
with this basically being like my job
now I'm going to treat it as my
profession and with that comes the
recognition that this has to be a more
professional environment and so you know
I'm still gonna talk to you guys and I
said on Twitter and all that kind of
stuff it's just the nature of the videos
that we make are going to be more
professional-looking videos I'm gonna
get like an actual vlogging can like a
handycam you know I'm gonna do like
professional-looking vlogs and ever I do
updates you know those are the kind of
things that we're gonna do because it's
high time that we move in that direction
you know at this point with a hundred
thousand subscribers we really can't
basically produce videos where it looks
like like I'm a kid in the basement we
can't have that anymore you know we got
to make this stuff look good and and I
think the better it is the more you guys
will like it I think I don't think it's
gonna be as bad as some of you guys
might think I think you guys are really
gonna love the direction that we're
going in but um but that leads me to to
the current events stuff the stuff that
we're gonna be getting into this is the
good stuff this is the stuff that you
guys have probably been wanting to
wanting to hear about this this whole
video so the first thing we're gonna do
is is we're gonna do incursions after
the first of the year and that's gonna
be a four-part series we're gonna do
like a proper video explaining the
Illuminati and that's one of the things
that I've been debating on while the
video is like like incursions part 1
will be anywhere between 9 to 10 minutes
I'm thinking about still keeping like
the character explanation or the group
explanation videos around like 10 to 15
minutes I think that's a really really
good time frame that way you guys can
get the stuff you need and I can still
you know keep the videos relatively
poignant but instead of filling you know
the I guess incursians videos with a
bunch of verb verbose fluff as a friend
of mine we'll call it we can just get to
the meat and potatoes and so it's gonna
be a four-part series on part 1 we'll
deal with the initial incursion when
Black Panther first discovers the
incursion and encounters Black Swan part
2 we'll go from there part 3 part 4 will
cover the infinity gems we'll talk about
during our Illuminati video how it is
the Illuminati gain the infinity gems
we'll talk about how Reed Richards
almost didn't give the Infinity Gauntlet
up and how Charles Xavier basically had
to step in
he didn't outright say it but at the end
of the comic you know that when the
watchers like I'm glad you were able to
give the supper you know I'm very proud
of you that Charles Xavier was like now
like I kind of made him do it he didn't
you know again he didn't really say it
but that's pretty much what he tells us
you know when we cover the Illuminati
you know we're going to talk about the
and the events that led up to secret
invasion because it wasn't as though the
scrolls just arbitrarily attacked the
planet Earth they actually took the
Illuminati and copied them like made
like copy their DNA and started making
copies of them you know we're gonna talk
about the Illuminati and you know I
guess when they're there initial for
their initial formation you know with
new Avengers with you know like the
century being introduced in the Marvel
Comics out of the Marvel Knights and all
that kind of stuff we're gonna get into
all those things um following incursions
because incursions is still going on and
incursions is actually going to lead
into the 2015 summer event following
incursions we're going to talk about
spider-verse and I think a lot of you
guys are gonna be really excited about
spider verse and just FYI for those of
you guys who are curious about all the
different versions of spider-man because
we're not gonna get into every single
version we're only gonna get in the ones
out of the most poignant to the actual
spider verse story for those of you guys
that want to know about all the
different versions of spider-man go
check out Benny's channel he's got like
like three or four videos I think with
like a hundred and seven different
versions of spider-man some of them are
just like it's this guy and he's here
and that's it and some of them are a
little more in depth than that but
they're really really cool series of
videos so um so make sure you guys check
that out and and yeah so so here's the
other thing since January first is gonna
be coming around and I'm actually gonna
be in the process of moving like that's
one of the reasons why I haven't
uploaded any videos is because one like
a Peter is dead but two if it wasn't it
would be a little sporadic because I'm
moving all my stuff but when January
first comes around the other question is
what are we gonna do about the older
videos the infinity war the Age of
Apocalypse stuff like that those videos
are gonna take a background we've got
years until the Age of Apocalypse comes
out we've got like I guess not really
age with Eclipse but x-men apocalypse
we've got two years until that comes out
infinity war we've got like like what
like four years or something like that
we've got a long time until those videos
or two those movies actually like hit
fears and so we've got plenty of time to
discuss these things and that's what
we're gonna do those older stories are
gonna fall into the background because
again it's high time that we get current
on this channel we really can't be
lagging behind with comics in the 1980s
and 1990s I know a lot of you older
comment
fans a lot of your really hardcore
coming but fans love that stuff and I'm
gonna do what I can to bring those
videos to you because I know that's what
you guys want to see but again we got to
get current we got to get picked up we
got to talk about the new stuff we got
to talk about Captain Falcon we got to
talk about you know I guess the events
after the death of Wolverine we got to
talk about Avengers vs. x-men you know
even spider-verse the deals with the
incursions there's a point where Roma
and Merlin are like we don't really know
what to do and they have one of the
spider-man like you know they I guess
they get with him and talk to him about
the incursions you know there's there's
a lot of different things that are going
on and a lot of the stuff that's taking
place right now it's going to lead
directly into the 2015 summer event and
so if we don't cover these things then
we're going to go into that event
playing catch-up and that's not what I
want to do I want to go into the 2015
summer event and give you guys the
rundown of what's happening as it's
happening without too much confusion
yeah there's there's all kinds of stuff
that we really need to talk about that
that's going on right now so that's what
we're gonna do but anyway I feel like I
feel like I'm in rambling this whole
time so I'm gonna go ahead and ring this
video to an end but but yeah so with
that being said we'll catch you guys
later peace